boy this is a tough one for me I've
struggled with this my whole career
because I go very much both ways first I
think way too many companies don't
promote youngsters fast enough I think
of business like sports you can be an
All-Pro as a rookie Kobe was just fine
at 18 and he was a superstar so why do
we not let superstars in work get
promoted quicker on the flip side we
over promoted aggressively in Vayner
media's history and wine library's
history and I have seen when I give
people too much responsibility too fast
it [ __ ] them up no different than me at
10 years old being great at baseball
they moved me up to the 13 to 15 year
old league and 11 year old Gary wasn't
ready for that [ __ ] heat and it
[ __ ] me up in baseball so this is a
balancing act when you see this headline
leaders and owners it's really down to
the individual there are absolutely
youngsters you should promote much
faster that's why so many of you are
losing great people but there's others
that need a little more slowdown and
training when they get their bat